beobachte ist ist gut nein nein nein Harmonika
habe ich früher gespielt
und
der ist da die kriegt er es hin ich finde
wir könnten aber auch mal den Leuten
[Applaus] oder anziehen vielen Dank danke
schön die Mannschaft wunderbar [Applaus]
wenn
so Doktor Kamera vielen dank vielen Dank ich
glaube ich muss jetzt gehen oder ja du musst
jetzt gehen
muss ich sagen nein das wäre nein weil das
was ich jetzt sah nein wäre nie gut wenn
ich sag wenn du noch da wärst geil ja weil
okay und jetzt verschwinden ich muss jetzt
sagen
ja
immer
[Musik]
Ärger mit der Nazis und da muss man aufpassen
weil Vorsicht sagen viele Krise in perikola
bonit ihr in eo moritor also wer sich in Gefahr
begibt der kommt in ihr um eine alte Weisheit
leicht abgeändert durch ein Bloch der gemeint
hatte wer sich nicht in Gefahr begibt der
kommt in ihr um und keine Angst vor Gefahr
keine Angst sich mit Rechten Populisten und
Publizisten oder kurz gesagt Nazis auseinanderzusetzen
das hat auch unser nächster Künstler nicht
denn er ist kein stranger vor danger er ist
danger denn der ausgezeichnete und dafür
zu Recht ausgezeichnete in der kleinen Musik
unintelligible denn habe ich schon gesagt
[Applaus] hau rein danger denn [Applaus] [Musik]
war ein Job einer mit flexibler Arbeitszeit
[Musik] jede Woche eine auf dem Rock Party
mit dem Chef
so ein Startup Unternehmen
[Musik] mit meinem Lebenslauf
und klebt ein sympathisches und seriöses
Foto drauf
als millorit erschien und sagte lauft davon
schwerer als reinzukommen ist es wieder rauszukommen
Lauf davon lauft davon lauft davon lauf doch
von so schnell du kannst bevor sie dich bekommen
lauft davon lauft davon und so schnell du
kannst
[Musik]
lu hat gesagt lauf doch von Anfang von vorne
an
dich das nicht gemacht will ich ganz bestimmt
verloren gegangen [Musik]
dieser Nacht habe ich mir meine Tasche gepackt
[Musik] Kaffeefleck
da habe ich mich ungefähr ein halbes Jahr
versteckt ich wusste nicht was ich da sollte
aber die Jungs in der Stadt
haben wir beigebracht wie man alte Autos aufknackt
lauft davon lauf doch von läuft davon
lauf doch von so schnell du kannst bevor sie
dich bekommen
läuft davon lauft davon so schnell du kannst
und von irgendwo noch mal von vorne an [Musik]
Ende Juni ein Plastik [Musik] wir hatten kein
Geld für Tickets doch der Zauber nicht hoch
natürlich wollen wir erwischt und von den
Flix verhauen
pepperspray hat noch tagelang gebrannt in
den Augen
ich Kamera alleine getanzt du warst schöner
als du eine Flasche Wein in der Hand
dann hat irgendwer gefragt warum ich weinen
muss
ich sagte wegen pepperspray da gab mir einen
Kuss lauft davon lauft davon lauft davon
lauft davon so schnell du kannst bevor sie
dich bekommen
so schnell du kannst
von irgendwo noch mal von vorne an [Musik]
[Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
[Musik] Hase jetzt mal ganz viel cooler tief
angenommen ich schriebe mal ein Lied in dessen
inhaltlich der Sänger darf sich höchstpersönlich
finde Jürgen elsässig und zum zweiten Teil
das für Strophe dann würde ich zu kubitsche
die Bogen spannen und damit meinte ich nicht
nur die rhetorische Figur sondern das Sportgerät
schießen kann juristisch [Musik] Spiel cooler
Typ ich nutze ganz bewusst die wahren Konjunktiv
ich schriebe einen Text im Konflikt mit dem
Gesetz behauptet reptiloid und dann genommen
der Text gipfelten einem Aufruf die Welt von
den Faschisten zu befreien und sie zurück
in ihre Löcher einzuführen auf dem Weg zu
streuen du wirst die schwer die brautzone
erreicht doch vor Gericht machte ich es mir
wieder leicht zeig mich an und ich auf Nein
Insekt das ist alles von der kunstreit gelegt
[Musik] vielleicht habt ihr schon mal von
gehört ein du der sich überhaupt sind so
sehr laut beschwert mit einem Text von meiner
Band dachte er wird der Welt und beschimpft
und hat uns vorgerichtet
er war natürlich nicht im rechten musste
dann hahaha die Gerichtskosten und Anwältin
bezahlen ja so ein lächerlicher Mann hoffentlich
zeigt er mich an was dann passieren würde
ich kann es euch sagen du bist so schwer die
grauzung erreicht doch vor Gericht machte
ich es mir wieder leicht zeig mich an und
ich öffne einen Sekt das ist alles von der
kunstheit gedeckt
nein ich lerne nicht wirklich danger denn
wenn ich nicht Lust hätte auf ein Experiment
mal die Grenzen auszuloten was erlaubt und
was verbotenes und will euch meine Meinung
hier erzählen Jürgen hält es aus Antisemit
Kubitschek hat Glück dass ich nicht bogenschießt
doch eher wie ein Nationalsozialist verschissen
zu sein und diskutiert mit ihm nicht hat die
Geschichte gezeigt man vertraut doch nicht
auf Start und Polizeiapparat bei der Verfassungsschutz
den NSU mit aufgebaut hat weil die Polizei
doch selbst war weil sie hurriciano gefesselt
und angezündet haben juristisch [Musik] vor
Gericht machen
und ich öffne einen Sekt das ist alles sonder
alles von mir alles von der alles von der
alles von der alles von der alles von der
alles alles von der Kunstfreiheit der [Musik]
[Applaus]